[Music]
so we had a very constructive discussion
on the multi financial framework in
Paris during the first three months we
have concentrated we have focused on the
negotiations of the European Parliament
on the sectoral related proposals of the
MFF the outcome was very positive since
we have managed to conclude 11
understandings common understandings
with the European Parliament on several
sessions sectoral logistic proposal and
substantial progress has been achieved
today we had the last time attic debate
with a focus on the external dimension
the budget emphasizing two key elements
namely the European Development Fund in
the European neighbourhood instrument
all this discussion was fed into the
preparation for a vice dragon
associating ball setting which is going
to be the major contribution Romanian
presidency the European capital to DM
ffs I already mentioned by the 90
Romania is going to come with an echo
box proposal and as well another issue
that is going to be important in the
European Cups is the climate change
issues a comb assault force lock a tatsu
and you know your home game at the
interim boiling via PC instrumented to
summon theorem when iron fell upon the
fear index godsend in fiddle team that
is a photo harmon how it right
understood solar
- Amanda in summary in forestry for news
a leap hoc committee also helped this
houses comments in Indian houses common
in decree at Dartmouth fallen where
Tahoe is unhooks mass and flexibility in
stinking
you